Qué factores pueden explicar que el
golpe a los demócratas esté siendo menor
a lo esperado ha podido movilizar a su
electorado la insinuación de Donald
Trump para presentarse de nuevo en 2024
Así es muy buenas noches
están muy contentos porque les fue mejor
de lo esperado lo que muchos temían era
una ola roja como decías y no se vio eso
al revés pudieron mantener muchos
lugares y ganaron varias gubernaturas y
bueno lo que vemos es que hubieron una
importante participación del electorado
sobre todo de los demócratas e
independientes y Esto fue un rechazo a
Trump y sus políticas y era una una
campaña muy difícil para los demócratas
dada la situación con la inflación y y
la guerra en Ucrania y demás no era esto
estaba fácil sin embargo los demócratas
mantuvieron muchos de sus estaños lo
cual pueden ver como una victoria claro
y de confirmarse esta postulación de
Donald Trump parece que podría
enfrentarse a ron de santis El ya
renovado gobernador de Florida con quien
mantiene una tensa disputa dialéctica
dentro del partido de dónde viene esta
enemistad entre ambos porque hoy ya ha
habido también ataques
Así es mucha gente ha encontrado una
carrera política dentro del partido
republicano al aliarse repetir las ideas
de Trump la la gran mentira sobre la
elección que le estaba funcionando
electoralmente a varios y en el caso de
la Florida le ha funcionado muy bien al
gobernador de santis Y entonces ahora lo
que están encontrando algunos
gobernadores el de Texas el de Florida
es que pueden
tomar el lugar de Trump siguiendo su
legado y tal vez heredar la base de
Trump sin embargo una cosa es pensarlo y
otra cosa es que la gente la base que
que apoya Trump los trompistas fueron a
votar por de santis entonces lo que está
pasando es crear una división dentro de
las primarias que es muy común cuando
hay elecciones para presidente sin
embargo están peleando ambos de santis y
Trump por los extremos de su partido
republicano Por lo cual tendrá que ser
la la la competencia bastante personal y
va a ser bastante ardua y va a debilitar
a los republicanos en en frente a las
próximas elecciones presidenciales